Seeing Jennifer Lopez performing
the role of a dancer in a movie
may not seem that surprising.
She's known for her moves.
But knowing how to dance
and knowing how to do this
are two very different things.
Turns out, even J-Lo needed some help
to get ready to assume her role
as an experienced pole
dancer in "Hustlers."
That's where 10-year
veteran of Cirque du Soleil
Johanna Sapakie comes in.
Johanna Sapakie: By the time
we were done working together,
even though it was just
a short period of time,
she's throwing out these moves
without even thinking about it anymore.
Narrator: So how did Sapakie
get Lopez to the point
where she was doing upside-down
splits in just two months?
Lopez took her training so seriously
that she moved a portable pole
into each one of her houses
in New York City, Los Angeles, and Miami,
so that she could continue to practice
wherever she happened to
be living at the time.
While Lopez was already
in fantastic shape,
pole dancing requires
certain muscle groups
to be extraordinarily strong.
And because there are no
body doubles in the film,
she had to do everything herself.
So, to get her ready for the role,
Sapakie first made sure that Lopez
was exercising the muscle
groups that she'd need
to pole dance like a pro.
Lopez worked with her personal trainer
to strengthen her core and upper body.
She had to make sure that
she was strong enough
to perform certain moves,
like the inverted splits,
where she's supporting
her entire body weight
with just her arms and shoulders.
As Lopez continued to
strengthen her body in the gym,
she also began her
pole-dancing training sessions
with Sapakie.
Sapakie says that each training session
always started with stretching.
It's important to loosen the
spine, shoulders, and hips
in order to provide a
wider range of motion
for the undulating movements
that are essential to pole dancing.
After stretching, Sapakie
slowly introduced Lopez
to the principles of pole dancing,
such as basic spins and climbing.
Sapakie: When we started, you
know, the trainings are slow.
You do one movement at a time.
You rest in between.
If you're not used to a lot of rotation,
getting the feeling of
spinning around the pole
takes a little bit of practice.
There's a lot of
conversation about, you know,
how to do the movement
and what the movement is.
Narrator: Sapakie also emphasized
improving Lopez's pole-dancing endurance.
She knew Lopez was going to have to do
her pole-dancing scenes
over and over and over again
throughout the day when they were filming.
Especially because her main routine
was a full four minutes long.
Sapakie: You're not just
doing one trick at a time.
You're linking things together
into, you know, two, three,
four minutes' worth of movement.
She's doing takes from different
angles over and over again,
and she has to nail it every single time.
Narrator: Because Sapakie
also choreographed
all of the pole-dancing
scenes in "Hustlers,"
she knew exactly what moves
Lopez was going to have
to perform for the film.
There were several
particularly difficult moves
in the choreography,
but Sapakie was confident
in Lopez's abilities.
Sapakie: There's one where
she actually wraps her legs
around the pole and just
squeezes with her inner thighs,
and that's all that
she's using to hold on.
And that definitely took some practice
because you really have to
engage those inner-thigh muscles
in order to hold yourself on the pole.
So that's not one that came on day one.
We definitely had to work up to that
in order to gain that
feeling and that strength.
Narrator: Once Lopez
started to get confident
with her pole dancing,
the last thing for her to master
was flipping upside down.
Sapakie: You wanna make
sure that physically
you're really capable
before you're inverting.
It takes a lot of core strength,
it takes a lot of grip strength,
and it takes a lot of upper-body strength
to physically pull yourself up
and then maintain that position safely.
Narrator: When Lopez was
first learning the move,
Sapakie would provide a spot for her,
making sure she was safe
as she tried to master the movement.
But it wasn't too long before she was able
to do it on her own.
Sapakie: She really became
comfortable with it quickly
because of her work ethic and
because she was so diligent
and determined to get it right.
She was able to achieve
her goal by the end,
which was turning upside down
and ultimately looking
like she's been doing this
her whole life.
And that was really exciting
to see and really satisfying.